-Anyone out here watching this
new show, "House of Dragons"?
[ Cheering and applause ]
I am the biggest
"Game of Thrones" fan.
I love their new show
and I got to tell you,
I love that they're including
Black characters,
but, to be honest,
the Black characters, um,
they take me out of it
a little bit with the --
it's that blonde hair
and the old-time accents.
It's a little jarring.
You're like,
"Where are these people from?"
You know what I mean?
And then they're coming out
with Season 2, I guess, soon
and, somehow, Lorne Michaels
arranged a sneak peek
of Season 2
of "House of Dragons."
Exclusive, so, check it out.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ "House of the Dragon"
theme song plays ]
-Before we go to war
with Kings Landing,
we must know
who our true allies are.
-These represent all of our
possible alliances, Your Grace.
-Thank you, Daemon.
-And I've prepared
this family tree
so we know who the hell
everyone is.
-Yes, because our names are
insane and sound identical.
-I've also prepared a chart
of who's having sex with whom
and, weirdly enough, it's the
same as the family tree.
-You have a visitor, Your Grace.
[ Door opens ]
Lord of the Tides,
the Sea Snake himself,
Corlys Velaryon.
-Lord Corlys, this is
a most welcome surprise.
Where have you come from?
-The Matrix.
Just kidding.
-You must've been at sea
a long time, then.
-Oh, of course.
This is where my people are
most comfortable, the ocean.
Yeah, we especially love
being on ships!
Never have any concerns
with ships
or what might happen to us
on ships.
-Have you come alone?
-Oh, no, no, I brought
my granddaughters,
Baela and Rhaena.
-Greetings, Your Grace.
-So happy to have traveled
40 days by ship
in this ball gown,
Your Grace.
-It's wonderful to see you
since you are betrothed
to my nephew/stepsons
Jace and Luke.
-Yes, I look at
my future husband, and I think,
he is definitely going to
satisfy me sexually.
-Mm-hmm.
-And to what do we owe
the honor of your visit,
Lord Corlys?
-Yeah, well, you know, I know
that you in need of allies
now that your father has died.
-Died? [ Groans ]
-Oh, my God, man.
What is happening
with your face?
-The doctor says it's nothing.
Just a little cough
and my skin melted
and my eye fell out.
-Well, I found you
some new allies
from even further-away lands
that have come to pay their
respects to the true queen.
-Well, well, well.
Good to see you, Your Grace.
Cousin Daemon, well, I haven't
seen you in a long time.
How does it feel
to have sex with your niece?
Yuck.
-This whole family looks like
the sun took a look and said,
"No, thank you."
[ Laughs ]
-Your Majesty,
looks like you got a case
of the monkey pox.
-[ Laughs ]
-You're going to die any minute,
ain't you?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Well, if it isn't our cousin,
light-skinned Larry Targaryen.
-[ Chuckles ]
Silky, your hoes are so old
their titties
give powdered milk.
-You look like E.T. when they
dressed him up for Halloween.
-Ha.
-Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey,
all that was hateful, man.
-Your Jheri curls
are getting a little dry.
-That's that dragon spray.
-More visitors approach.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Pardon me, Your Grace,
but I think your penis
just fell off.
If you don't want it anymore,
can I keep it?
Might be able
to get some money for that.
-Who is this foul man?
-I came here
for some dragon rocks.
I'm down to my last one.
-What the hell
is going on here?
-You mind if I, um,
get a light?
Dracarys.
-Be gone, all of you.
-Oh, no, there's more.
-I'm one of the baddest mother
[bleep] Westeros has ever seen.
One of the best singers and
one of the best dancers, too.
I'm Aegon Targaryen, bitch,
rider of dragons.
I heard you like
to ride lizards.
Want to ride mine,
Your freaking Majesty?
-[ Roars ]
-Take me to Flea Bottom
so I can check on my hoes.
-What up, Tar?
I got a dragon now.
-[Bleep] No, dragon.
[Bleep] No, dragon.
[ Siren chirps ]
-Good God, it's the police.
What are they doing
all the way up here?
No matter how high I fly,
they always find you,
don't they?